[Music]
good morning John it's shmurda flipped
over swap is that good enough for you
cuz that's good enough for me
I'm gonna do something a little bit
different right now maybe this
two-year-old is so excited about being
able to tango on his own that he
sometimes takes out the equipment before
going to the bathroom and then sort of
waddles into the bathroom while everyone
laughs and then maybe later
five-year-old me points out to the
two-year-old nameless person that you
can't take the equipment out until
you're inside the bathroom with the door
closed John I have a suspicion I don't
think that you sent to me don't take the
equipment up before the door is closed I
have that suspicion even though I can't
remember this because I've been your
mother for a long time and during that
time you've been very good at pointing
out when I do things that are socially
irregular but I can't seem to remember a
time during the first 13 years of my
life in which you did that in a kind way
and that is how I got a scar on my
knuckle from your braces this may
surprise Brotherhood 2.0 viewers when I
was generally the more physical of the
brothers well John's abusin generally
came out of his mouth my abuse one time
landed on his mouth no our relationship
has never been perfect in fact it was
touch-and-go for a while there the the
video blogging is good though because we
get to convey our entire sentiments
without interrupting each other and I
don't actually have to physically occupy
the same space as you and other siblings
may be able to attest to the fact that 3
minutes a day is probably a very
manageable dosage of sibling also it's
nice that I have cognitively developed
the same stage as you so you can no
longer pick on me for being
developmentally in superior yeah I could
however continue to pick on you for
being physically in superior I don't
know if anyone out there has ever asked
John how tall he is but he has this
charming way of saying that he's 6 foot
1 which is strange because I am 6 foot 1
and when John and I stand back-to-back I
am more than an inch taller than him
maybe John's doctors little height
measuring things broken I don't know
maybe that's the problem
or maybe he just doesn't want to admit
but his little brother is taller than
him seriously I love you your good guy I
think that we're over
the anger bite verbal jabs so never we
would never verbally jab at one another
anymore but that was kind of the only
way I could respond to you back then
I didn't have the same sharp wit that
you developed so I can only respond to
your verbal attacks with physical
attacks or you know just running away I
did that more then punching do you
remember the punch thing we were over at
Nick Jones's house
you look really surprised was mostly
what I remember you were surprised and
my hand hurt no no I remember now you
got really angry too you got really
angry not because it hurt but because
you were afraid that I had messed up
your braces which is pretty much the
nerdiest response to getting punched in
the mouth ever oh my God my orthodontics
might be messed up nerds the life so
based on the theme of this video I have
a question for the nerdfighters have you
ever been in a fight and if you have how
did it go and why did you fight and do
you think it was worth it I would love
to see those answers there or you can
put them in my pants which is the
Brotherhood tube in a forum if you were
confused and of course video responses
are always our favorite we've kind of
given up the that form of communication
but it is a form of communication it's
it's a way to say something and in my
opinion it can be very effective and
even in some cases appropriate form of
communication so I'm as curious about
you guys opinions and experiences with a
physical communication physical
communication is not immediately bring
mind fights the combative physical
communication so I would love to read /
hear your words on that topic Thanks
that is all for today John I'll see you
tomorrow